This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When you're the parent of a small child, it's not uncommon to have an experience like this. Your kid comes home from preschool and says, the butterfly flew away. You go, what butterfly? And your child looks at you puzzled. She doesn't realize that the butterfly she saw at preschool,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当你是一个幼儿的父母时，经历这样的事情并不少见。你的孩子从幼儿园回家后说，蝴蝶飞走了。你问，什么蝴蝶？然后你的孩子迷惑地看着你。她没有意识到她在幼儿园看到的蝴蝶，
when you were not around is not a butterfly you know anything about. In the minds of very small children, there is no sharp line between what they know and what others know. But at some point early in childhood, all of us made a magical discovery. Our thoughts belong only to us. Parents, siblings, teachers, no one can enter our minds and see what we are thinking. A second discovery follows shortly afterward. If no one can see what is happening inside our minds, we can hide things from other people. We can keep secrets.
在你不在的时候，并不是你所知道的蝴蝶。在幼小的孩子心中，他们所知道的和别人所知道的之间没有清晰的界限。但在童年早期的某个时刻，我们所有人都做了一个神奇的发现。我们的想法只属于我们自己。父母、兄弟姐妹、老师，没有人能进入我们的大脑看到我们在想什么。紧接着是第二个发现。如果没有人能看到我们大脑内部发生的事情，我们可以向其他人隐瞒事情。我们可以保守秘密。
So the pain of keeping this secret has been one of the biggest challenges I've had to deal with in my adult life. I do think constantly about it and I can't tell anybody about it now. Because I'm afraid of what might happen and it's affected my overall well-being. This week on Hidden Brain, how secrets tether us to our past and sometimes keep us from stepping into the future. So often, the secrets that we keep start out as something small. We make tiny edits to our personal narratives. We skip over little details about where we come from, what we've done, and who we know. We hide pieces of ourselves that produce shame or anxiety. But over time, the weight of
因此，保守这个秘密的痛苦一直是我成年后不得不应对的最大挑战之一。我确实一直在想着它，现在我还不能告诉任何人。因为我害怕可能会发生的事情，这影响了我的整体健康。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，秘密是如何将我们与过去栓在一起，有时又阻止我们迈向未来的。很多时候，我们保守的秘密都是从微小的事情开始的。我们对个人经历做微小的修改。我们略过关于我们来自哪里、我们做过什么以及我们认识谁的小细节。我们隐藏了产生羞耻感或焦虑感的自我碎片。但随着时间的推移，
even small secrets can become burdensome. Lauren Ladouk knows exactly how this works. She's in her knows exactly how this works. She's in her early 20s and works in a pharmacy. But I'm also a fiancé, a daughter, a sibling, an older sibling to seven. I'm also a student. I'm in my master's, trying to get into medical school at the moment.
即使是小秘密的重量也可能变成一种负担。劳伦·拉杜克非常清楚这是怎么回事。她刚出头，非常清楚这是怎么回事。她二十出头，在一家药店工作。但我也是一个未婚妻、一个女儿、一个兄弟姐妹，是七个孩子中的老大。我也是个学生。我正在读硕士，目前正试图进入医学院。
Lauren's secret has to do with religion. She was raised Catholic, when she was a teenager, she turned away from Catholicism. But she didn't want to give up on religion altogether. I just didn't know what to believe in, but I knew that I was still believing in God. She started to explore other faiths, Islam, Judaism, Buddhism. She sought out people
劳伦的秘密与宗教有关。她是在天主教环境中长大的，当她十几岁时，她背离了天主教。但她并不想彻底放弃宗教。我只是不知道该相信什么，但我知道我仍然信仰上帝。她开始探索其他信仰，伊斯兰教、犹太教、佛教。她寻找不同宗教传统的人
from different religious traditions and peppered them with questions. For example, I would try and find someone in high school or on my campus that was a practicing Buddhist and just asked questions about that religion. One of her religious consultants was a boy named Hamza. I was on student council. He was on the media production team, and we were actually playing a kickball game, and he scored a home run, and sophomore me was like, oh, that's the coolest guy ever.
向他们提出各种问题。例如，我会试着在高中或校园里找一个信奉佛教的人，然后问一些关于那个宗教的问题。她的一位宗教顾问是一个名叫哈姆扎的男孩。我在学生会。他在制作团队，我们当时在玩踢球游戏，他打出了一场本垒打，我这个高二学生心想，哦，这是有史以来最酷的家伙。
Hamza, in addition to being the coolest guy ever, was Muslim. It was nice to have someone who was actually faithfully a part of their religion, whose family practiced it, who he seemed to really enjoy it. Hamza and Lauren began dating some months later. Eventually, as she spoke with him and other practicing Muslims about what it meant to be a person of faith, Lauren decided that Islam was the right fit for her. In her senior year of high school, she converted.
哈姆扎除了是有史以来最酷的家伙之外，还是个穆斯林。很高兴能有一个真正忠实于自己宗教的人，他的家人也信仰它，而且他似乎真的很享受。几个月后，哈姆扎和劳伦开始约会。最终，在与他和其它虔诚的穆斯林交谈关于作为一个有信仰的人意味着什么之后，劳伦决定伊斯兰教最适合她。在她高中的最后一年，她皈依了。
This was when her dilemma began. She didn't want people to assume that Hamza was the reason she had embraced Islam. Where they think I did it for a boy. So she decided to fudge one tiny detail. Whenever I meet people and they ask about this, I ultimately end up emphasizing the point, yes, I converted before I met him. But that's not how it happened. It was the other way around. I met my boyfriend and then I converted.
这就是她的困境开始的时候。她不想让别人以为哈姆扎是她皈依伊斯兰教的原因。他们认为我是为了一个男孩才这么做的。因此，她决定掩饰一个小细节。每当遇到别人问起这件事，我最终都会强调这一点，是的，我在遇到他之前就皈依了。但事情不是这样的。事实正好相反。我遇到了我的男朋友，然后我才皈依的。
I see the conversion is not the secret, but the timing of the conversion. You're actually in some ways you're predating when you actually converted because of your concerns about how people will perceive you. Yes, exactly. If people thought Lauren had converted to please her boyfriend, she worried they might make other assumptions about her. She just does whatever she's told, she's gullible. She doesn't have her own set of values or her own thinking.
我认为皈依不是秘密，而是皈依的时间。实际上，由于你担心别人会如何看待你，你在某种程度上把你的实际皈依时间提前了。是的，完全正确。如果人们认为劳伦皈依是为了取悦她的男朋友，她担心他们可能会对她做出其他假设。她只是听从别人的吩咐，她很容易受骗。她没有自己的价值观或自己的想法。
And she just did this for a boy. She's hopeless, romantic. So for anyone to identify me with those traits, it would just be so hopeful. So my self esteemed, my confidence. Lauren saw herself as motivated, strong, decisive. And when it came to religion, she knew her choices were entirely her own. How Ivy religion is just me and God.
她这么做只是为了一个男孩。她无可救药，是个浪漫主义者。因此，如果任何人将我与这些特质联系在一起，那将是无可救药的。所以我的自尊心，我的自信。劳伦视自己为积极主动、坚强、果断的人。当涉及到宗教时，她知道自己的选择完全是她自己的。我的宗教信仰只是我和上帝之间的事。
It shouldn't involve anyone else. It should just be a one-on-one relationship. At first, the little lie made everything easier. She didn't have to explain to people that she would have made the same choice, whether or not she was with Hamza. Just don't tell them, tell them a short synopsis, make it easy into the point. Easy and to the point. Easy and to the point. That was the hope, but like many secrets, this one slowly took on a life of its own.
它不应该涉及任何人。这应该只是一对一的关系。起初，这个小谎言让一切都变得更容易了。她不必向人们解释，无论她是否和哈姆扎在一起，她都会做出同样的选择。只要不告诉他们，告诉他们一个简短的概要，简单明了。简单明了。简单明了。这就是希望，但像许多秘密一样，这个秘密慢慢地有了它自己的生命。
After high school, Lauren got a job as a pharmacy technician. When I talked to her, she had been working at the pharmacy for more than four years. The altar timeline for her religious conversion was the story she shared with colleagues. But as time passed, the little lie became harder to manage. Somebody was talking about me and Homsa and the timeline of how we met. And I was like, oh crap, what did I tell them? I need to make sure that my story is correct, because I told them maybe a year ago one story.
高中毕业后，劳伦在一家药店当技术员。当我跟她交谈时，她已经在药店工作了四年多。她皈依宗教的替代时间线是她与同事分享的故事。但随着时间的推移，这个小谎言变得更难管理了。有人在谈论我和霍姆萨以及我们相遇的时间线。我想，哦，糟了，我跟他们说了什么？我需要确保我的故事是正确的，因为我大约在一年前告诉过他们一个故事。
I know, so I'm having to keep track of what I'm saying. And that's something that I do fear, that I told somebody something maybe a year ago about our relationship and then they catch me on it. Soon, there was another complication. Hamza. He just flat out tells people that this is whenever we started dating and then I converted and then we got engaged. So he doesn't mind,
我知道，所以我必须记住我在说什么。这也是我害怕的一点，我大约在一年前告诉过别人关于我们关系的事，然后他们抓住了我的把柄。不久，又出现了另一个复杂情况。哈姆扎。他直接告诉人们这是我们开始约会的时间，然后我皈依了，然后我们订婚了。所以他不介意，
he's not afraid of people so he just tells them the exact story which is also kind of scary for me because I'm like, oh my gosh, what if one of your people comes to me and then you know, I'm like, hamsa stop, we to go with my story, and he's like, people probably already know. And like, they don't know because I'm telling them this, and you're telling them that. Lawrence Waries started to spill into her life. There were nights she couldn't sleep
他不怕别人，所以他直接告诉他们确切的故事，这也让我觉得有点害怕，因为我想，哦天哪，如果你们的人来找我，然后你知道的，我说，哈姆扎，住手，我们得按我的故事来，他说，人们可能已经知道了。就像，他们不知道，因为我告诉他们这个，你告诉他们那个。劳伦的担忧开始蔓延到她的生活中。有些夜晚她无法入睡
as she tried to remember all the angles. What she'd said to whom, what Hamza may have said, how people might cross reference the stories and discover the truth. And then her worst fears were realized. We know this one couple, a husband and wife, and I guess he told the husband and the husband told the wife, and then the wife was asking me one day, oh yeah, how did y'all get together and tell me your story? And she's one of the less conservative people that I know and she's also Muslim.
当她试图记住所有的角度时。她对谁说过什么，哈姆扎可能说过什么，人们会如何交叉核对这些故事并发现真相。然后她最可怕的噩梦成真了。我们认识一对夫妇，丈夫和妻子，我想他告诉了丈夫，丈夫告诉了妻子，然后妻子有一天问我，哦，对了，你们是怎么在一起的，把你们的故事告诉我？她是我认识的不那么保守的人之一，她也是个穆斯林。
But I was telling her the shortened version and she's like, you know, my husband told me something different. The other woman was understanding. She assumed Lauren had made up the story in order not to offend conservative relatives who didn't know when Lauren and Hamza started dating But increasingly, Lauren found the mental gymnastics of keeping her secret exhausting She also started to feel bad about misleading people
但我告诉她的是简短的版本，她说，你知道，我丈夫告诉我一些不同的事情。另一位女士很理解。她以为劳伦编造这个故事是为了不冒犯不知道劳伦和哈姆扎什么时候开始约会的保守亲戚。但劳伦越来越觉得保守秘密的心理体操让人精疲力竭。她也开始为误导别人感到难过
She felt really bad about deceiving one particular coworker who had become a friend. She's amazing. Every time I come to the pharmacy now, she's like, hey, Bestie, and we really bonded because we both have dogs and our love for dogs, which is really awesome. Hmm. Hmm. But it's interesting that I'm wondering how this person in the pharmacy would feel if she knew that you had liked to her about something trivial.
她为欺骗一个已经成为朋友的特定同事感到非常难过。她太棒了。现在我每次去药店，她都会说，嘿，闺蜜，我们真的建立起了深厚的感情，因为我们都有狗，我们对狗的爱，这真的很棒。嗯。嗯。但这很有趣，我想知道药店里的这个人如果知道你为了一件琐事对她撒了谎，她会怎么想。
How do you think that she would take that? So part of my anxiety right now that I'm actively having is what will people think? Whenever they hear this, will they think that I've been lying to them or I haven't been a faithful friend or coworker? How will they react? Right. I mean, in your case, I think the lie is sort of a relatively trivial thing. But I can see how in life, there are people who put on roles and put on acts and basically
你觉得她会怎么想？所以我现在正在积极经历的部分焦虑是，别人会怎么想？每当他们听到这个，他们会认为我对他们撒了谎，或者我不是一个忠诚的朋友或同事吗？他们会有什么反应？对。我的意思是，在你的情况下，我认为这个谎言某种程度上是一件相对微不足道的事情。但我能理解在生活中，有些人扮演角色，扮演戏剧，基本上
you know, live those roles and acts not for, you know, months and weeks, but for years, for decades. And then, you know, 30 years, 40 years, 50 years on, they essentially feel like they've lived an inauthentic life. Yes, yes. So that is something that I want to avoid. One of those keywords, they're inauthentical life. So I'm still young, where I consider myself young, I'm 22. So I definitely want to just get this behind me and be okay and open with accepting who
你知道，生活在那些角色和戏份中，不是为了，你知道的，几个月和几周，而是几年，几十年。然后，你知道的，30年，40年，50年过去后，他们基本上觉得自己过着虚假的生活。是的，是的。所以这是我想要避免的事情。其中一个关键词，他们虚假的生活。所以我还年轻，或者我认为自己年轻，我22岁。所以我绝对想把这一切抛在脑后，变得坦然，并公开接受我是谁
I actually am and my actual timeline in life and stop fabricating this timeline because that's one step closer to just becoming me, Lauren, and not keeping this lie and being afraid of the timeline that I've had in life, I think it'll even bring me even closer to my religion if I'm just super accepting of why I converted, when I converted, in how I did it. Lauren's secret started out small, but it gradually took up more and more mental space. It left her feeling isolated from people who mattered to her. And that, it turns out, is the rub when it comes to secrets. When we come back, we speak with a researcher who studies secrets and ask him to analyze Lauren's story.
实际上我是谁，以及我实际的生活时间线，停止捏造这个时间线，因为那是更接近成为真正的我——劳伦的一步，不再保守这个谎言，不再害怕我的人生时间线，我想如果我超级接受我为什么皈依、什么时候皈依以及我是如何皈依的，这甚至会让我更接近我的宗教信仰。劳伦的秘密始于微小，但它逐渐占据了越来越多的大脑空间。这让她感到与对她重要的人隔绝了。事实证明，这就是保守秘密的关键所在。当我们回来时，我们将与一位研究秘密的研究人员交谈，并请他分析劳伦的故事。
He also explains what psychological studies reveal about the consequences of secret keeping. It's not having to hide a secret, it's having to live with it alone. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Michael Slepian is a psychologist at Columbia Business School. He studies secrets. Across a number of research studies, he finds that holding onto secrets
他还解释了心理学研究揭示的保守秘密的后果。不是不得不隐藏一个秘密，而是不得不独自承受它。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。迈克尔·斯莱皮安是哥伦比亚商学院的心理学家。他研究秘密。在许多研究中，他发现保守秘密
has profound effects on our well-being, but not for the reason most of us think. Michael Slepian, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's good to be here. When most of us think of keeping secrets, Michael, or the challenge of keeping secrets, what do we think about? When we think about a secret, sort of what people tend to imagine is one person sitting in a room with another person, and you're talking about something related to the secret, and the person with the secret has to carefully dodge questions,
对我们的健康有着深远的影响，但原因并不是我们大多数人想象的那样。迈克尔·斯莱皮安，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。迈克尔，当大多数人想到保守秘密，或者保守秘密的挑战时，我们在想什么？当我们想到秘密时，人们倾向于想象的是一个人和另一个人坐在一个房间里，你们在谈论与秘密相关的事情，保守秘密的人必须小心翼翼地回避问题，
and make sure to not reveal the wrong information, and that certainly happens sometimes. But it turns out we don't actually have to hide our secrets very frequently. It also turns out to be not the reason why they heard us. I'm thinking actually of the scene from the TV show The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel, which I think encapsulates the conventional way most of us think of secrets. One of the characters, whose name is Rose, is trying to find out information about her son, Noah. He has a top secret job at a top secret agency, and Rose is trying to get her daughter-in-law asterisk to spill the beans. So, do you call his university the company?
并确保不透露错误的信息，这种情况有时确实会发生。但事实证明，我们实际上并不需要经常隐藏我们的秘密。事实证明，这也并不是它们伤害我们的原因。其实我想到的是电视剧《了不起的麦瑟尔夫人》中的一个场景，我认为这概括了我们大多数人对秘密的传统看法。其中一个名叫罗斯的角色正试图打听关于她儿子诺亚的信息。他在一个绝密的机构里做着绝密的工作，而罗斯正试图让她的儿媳妇说漏嘴。那么，你管他的大学叫公司吗？
Sorry, no. Or the other place he works is the company. I say there is another place. He's blinded. Why didn't he know? Well, does he keep the touch when he's away? He usually can. But if he's away, you need to reach him. Are you able to? I really? What would you do in an emergency? Well, I don't know. He can just dial the operator and say, give me the CIA. It doesn't work that way. Of course not.
抱歉，没有。或者他工作的另一个地方是公司。我说还有另一个地方。他被蒙在鼓里。为什么他不知道？嗯，他不在的时候保持联系吗？他通常可以。但是如果他不在，你需要联系他。你能做到吗？我真的？如果在紧急情况下你会怎么做？嗯，我不知道。他可以拨打接线员电话说，给我接中情局。事情不是这样的。当然不是。
And Michael, of course, this is what we think when we think about keeping secrets, the moment of trying to hide something from someone and feeling flustered as they as they fished out of us. Yeah, and so if that was all that was harmful about secrecy, that would actually be quite good because we're not often in these conversations, but unfortunately, even when we're not talking to someone about something related to the secret, we have all the time in the world to simply think about that secret. And for our mind to return to that secret, I get it again. And this is where the real harm of secrets he seems to see been.
当然，迈克尔，这就是我们想到保守秘密时的想法，试图向某人隐瞒某事的那一刻，当他们从我们这里套话时感到慌乱。是的，如果这就是保守秘密有害的全部原因，那其实还挺好的，因为我们不常进行这样的对话，但不幸的是，即使我们没有和某人谈论与秘密相关的事情，我们也有全世界的时间去简单地思考那个秘密。并让我们的脑海再次回到那个秘密。这就是秘密真正危害似乎所在的地方。
Not moments when you have to hide the secret, but moments when you find yourself just having to think about it. And you find this in a number of studies that no one is usually behaving like the nosy mom, no one's asking us to reveal our secret because of course they don't even know that we have a secret. Yeah, you know, you could think about sort of a common secret, for example, is say infidelity. That's not a thing we go around asking our friends and family about, hey, have you ever cheated on your partner? It's just doesn't work that way. So if concealing the truth from prying eyes is not what makes secret keeping hard or keeping secrets hard,
不是你必须隐藏秘密的时刻，而是你发现自己不得不去想它的时刻。你在许多研究中发现这一点，通常没有人表现得像个爱管闲事的妈妈，没有人要求我们泄露秘密，因为他们当然甚至不知道我们有秘密。是的，你知道的，你可以想想一个常见的秘密，例如，婚外情。这不是我们会去问朋友和家人的事情，嘿，你曾经对你的伴侣不忠吗？根本行不通。因此，如果向窥探的眼睛隐瞒真相并不是保守秘密变得困难的原因，
what have you found is the real psychological cost of keeping secrets? So, when you're keeping a secret, what you're not doing is you're not letting people in on something that probably really matters to you. Otherwise, if you didn't care about it, you might feel free to talk about it. When you choose to be alone with something, you're often yourself for it. If it's something you need help with, now you're not getting the help you need. If it's something you need emotional support for, now you're not getting that either. So we're missing out on a lot of things when we're keeping a secret. And if you only have a secret to yourself, will you only have yourself to figure it out and you're going to find yourself turning that secret over and over in your mind and potentially ruminating on him.
你发现保守秘密的真正心理成本是什么？所以，当你保守一个秘密时，你没有做的是你没有让人们了解可能对你真的很重要的事情。否则，如果你不在乎，你可能会觉得可以自由谈论它。当你选择独自承受某事时，你往往是为自己承担。如果这是你需要帮助的事情，现在你没有得到你需要的帮助。如果这是你需要情感支持的事情，现在你也没有得到它。所以当我们保守秘密时，我们错过了很多东西。如果你只有自己知道的秘密，你就只有自己去弄清楚它，你会发现自己在脑海中一遍又一遍地翻转那个秘密，并有可能对它进行反刍。
And that's where we see the harm. It's not having to hide a secret, it's having to live with it alone. Did you hear any of that in Lauren's story, Michael? Yeah. And this is what's story, Michael? Yeah. And this is what's so interesting about secrecy. I think we think about these sort of specific kinds of secrets, you know, infidelity or cheating or something involving our relationships or finances. And, you know, something like, say, the timeline of events may not seem like a big deal to
这就是我们看到危害的地方。不是不得不隐藏秘密，而是不得不独自承受它。迈克尔，你在劳伦的故事里听到这些了吗？是的。这就是秘密如此有趣的地方。我想我们想到的是这些特定种类的秘密，你知道的，婚外情或出轨，或者涉及我们关系或财务的事情。而且，你知道的，比如说，事件的时间线对某些人来说可能不是什么大不了的事，
certain people, but it's the implications that we're concerned about. And again, I didn't get the sense that people were pushing her to reveal her timeline on those details of her story, but still it was something that really mattered to her. And it clearly was something that was on her mind quite frequently. One of the things that was striking to me that I thought spoke to the work that you've done is how much what was happening was happening inside her own mind. In other words, I'm not even sure this actually is a secret that mattered very much to other
但我们关心的是它的影响。而且，我并不觉得人们在逼迫她透露她的时间线或她故事的细节，但它仍然是对她来说真正重要的事情。而且这显然是她经常想起的事情。让我震惊并认为符合你所做的工作的一点是，发生的事情很大一部分是在她自己的脑海中发生的。换句话说，我不确定这实际上是一个对其他人非常重要或者会带来她所认为的声誉担忧的秘密。
people or would have the reputational concerns that she thought it was going to have. So much of the secret keeping, the effects of secret keeping, the psychological consequences, all of that was happening inside Lauren's head. Exactly. And that's what we see in our own research that a lot of it is sort of in your own head and in that way. And it's taken psychology a long time to find that idea
很大一部分保守秘密、保守秘密的影响、心理后果，所有这些都发生在劳伦的脑海里。完全正确。这正是我们在自己的研究中所看到的，很多事情都在你自己的脑海中，并且以这种方式。心理学花了好长时间才发现这个想法，
because we were sort of focused for too long on these sort of moments of hiding. That turns out to be not where the real action is in terms of when secrets actually harm us. In other words, it's not necessarily the real action is in terms of when secrets actually harm us. In other words, it's not necessarily the content of a secret that damages our well-being. It's the rumination and worry about what would happen if the secret came to light that ends up being a burden. Of course, like Lauren, most of us don't foresee all the complexities that can emerge when we keep a secret. This is partly why secret keeping is so ubiquitous. Michael found in one of his studies that we not only tend to keep a lot of secrets, we all tend to keep the same kinds of secrets.
因为我们对这些隐藏的时刻关注了太长时间。事实证明，这并不是秘密真正伤害我们的核心所在。换句话说，这不一定是秘密的内容损害了我们的健康。最终成为负担的是对秘密曝光后会发生什么的反复思考和担忧。当然，像劳伦一样，我们大多数人也无法预料保守秘密时可能出现的种种复杂情况。这部分就是为什么保守秘密无处不在的原因。迈克尔在他的其中一项研究中发现，我们不仅倾向于保守很多秘密，我们还倾向于保守同一种秘密。
So we asked a couple thousand people about what's this secret you're currently keeping, and we've coded those responses over and over with research assistants and are eventually right at a set of 38 categories that capture the most common kinds of secrets people keep. And when I say common, I really mean that these are the common ones that these 38 categories really cover the ground of secrecy pretty well. When we ask someone whether they have any secrets
因此，我们问了几千人关于他们目前正在保守的秘密是什么，我们和研究助理一遍又一遍地对这些回答进行编码，最终得出了一套38个类别，涵盖了人们保守的最常见的秘密。当我说常见时，我真的是指这些是常见的，这38个类别确实很好地涵盖了秘密的范围。当我们问某人他们是否有这个列表上的任何秘密时，
on this list, 97% of people have at least one of the secrets on this list, and the average person has 13 of these secrets concurrently. What kind of secrets are these? So you're not going to be surprised at all. It's going to be exactly the kinds of things you think people would be keeping secrets. With things involving relationships, whether that's romantic discontent or infidelity or something we call extra relational thoughts. This is very common secret.
97%的人都有列表上的至少一个秘密，平均每个人同时拥有13个这些秘密。这些都是什么秘密？所以你一点也不会感到惊讶。这正是你认为人们会保守秘密的那类事情。涉及关系的事情，无论是浪漫的不满、婚外情还是我们称之为关系外的想法。这是一个非常普遍的秘密。
You're in a relationship. You have some kind of romantic thought about another person. People tend to not talk about that. And then things like self-harm, experience of trauma, discontent at work, or discontent with your social life, issues around money and habits and addictions and even ambitions. Secretkeeping tends to trigger mind games. We start out by asking what other people will think of us if they knew our secret. We decide they will think less of us, which is why we decide to hide something. which is why we decide to hide something. But soon we find ourselves asking different questions. What happens if people find out I've hidden something from them? What will they think of me now?
你在恋爱中。你对另一个人有一些浪漫的想法。人们往往不谈论这个。然后是诸如自残、创伤经历、对工作的不满、对社交生活的不满、金钱问题、习惯、成瘾甚至野心。保守秘密往往会引发心理游戏。我们首先问的是，如果我们保守的秘密被别人知道了，他们会怎么看我们。我们认为他们会看轻我们，这就是我们决定隐藏秘密的原因，这就是我们决定隐藏秘密的原因。但很快我们发现自己在问不同的问题。如果人们发现我向他们隐瞒了什么会发生什么？他们现在会怎么看我？
In the sopranos, the hit TV show about the mob, Tony soprano does something unthinkable for a macho killer. He suffers a meltdown and goes to see a therapist. My understanding from Dr. Kusumano, your family physician, is that you collapsed, possibly a panic attack. You were unable to breathe? Days that it was a panic attack.
在黑帮热门电视剧《黑道家族》中，托尼·索普拉诺做了一件对于一个大男子主义杀手来说不可思议的事情。他崩溃了并去看心理医生。根据你的家庭医生库苏马诺医生的说法，你晕倒了，可能是恐慌发作。你呼吸困难？说那是恐慌发作。
Of course all the blood work and the neurological work came back negative. They sent me here. You don't agree that you had a panic attack. How are you feeling now? Good. Fine. Back at work. What line of work are you in? Waste management consultant. So this is a scene that you must have thought about as you are doing your research, Michael?
当然，所有的血液检查和神经学检查结果都是阴性的。他们把你送到这里来。你不同意你曾恐慌发作吗？你现在感觉怎么样？很好。很好。回去工作了。你是做什么工作的？废物管理顾问。所以迈克尔，你在做研究时一定想过这个场景吧？
Absolutely. What I really like about this example is it highlights that a secret can be really burdensome and it's not at all hard to hide. Tony just said, waste management without difficulty and it's not hard all hard to hide. Tony just said, waste management without difficulty and it's not hard for him to simply just use that as a way to cover the secret. He can just simply say two words and the concealment problem is super easy.
绝对的。我非常喜欢这个例子的是，它突显了一个秘密可以是非常沉重的负担，而且隐藏起来一点也不难。托尼轻描淡写地说了句废物管理，隐藏起来一点也不难。托尼轻描淡写地说了句废物管理，隐藏起来一点也不难，对他来说，简单地用这个来掩盖秘密并不难。他只需要简单地说两个字，隐瞒问题就变得超级简单。
And so you would think if the problem with secrecy was having concealment that this would be a really easy secret for him. And in fact, it's far from it. The conceit of the television show is that when the mobster goes to see the psychologist, at some point, this is unthinkable for a mobster to do and it would harm the mobster's reputation. Tony then goes to great lengths to try and preserve the secret that he's actually seeing a therapist from his fellow mobsters.
所以你会认为，如果保守秘密的问题在于隐瞒，这对她来说会是一个非常简单的秘密。事实上，远非如此。这部电视剧的构思是，当黑帮分子去看心理医生时，在某种程度上，这对于黑帮分子来说是不可思议的，并且会损害黑帮分子的声誉。托尼随后不遗余力地试图向他的黑帮同伙保守他实际上在看心理医生的秘密。
And it starts to affect him at some level in terms of his own perception of himself. I'm wondering if you can talk about this idea that keeping secrets at some level damages our own view of ourselves, and in some ways harms our ability to think of ourselves as being authentic people. Yes. So, when we're holding secret back from other people, we're not having these conversations about these things, you know, and this is what we can never realize if we don't talk about this secret with other people. People are generally understanding, especially with the people who are
这开始在某种程度上影响到他对自己的看法。我想知道你是否能谈谈这个想法，即在某种程度上保守秘密会损害我们对自己的看法，并在某些方面损害我们认为自己是真实的人的能力。是的。所以，当我们对其他人保守秘密时，我们没有就这些事情进行对话，你知道，如果我们不与其他人谈论这个秘密，我们永远不会意识到这一点。人们通常是通情达理的，尤其是与你亲近的人。
close to you. You know, maybe it's going to be quite difficult to talk about the secret, but you can, and it often makes things better, we find. You've also looked at secret keeping in the context of politics, Michael. You ran an interesting experiment, I think, right after the 2016 presidential election, which is, of course, between Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton. What was the experiment you ran, and what did you find? So when we ran this study, we were thinking, we had a very clear idea about who might be in our study.
你知道，也许谈论这个秘密会相当困难，但你可以，而且我们发现这通常会让事情变得更好。迈克尔，你还研究了政治背景下的保守秘密。我想，就在2016年总统大选之后，你做了一个有趣的实验，当时选举当然是在唐纳德·特朗普和希拉里·克林顿之间进行的。你做了什么实验，你发现了什么？所以当我们做这项研究时，我们在想，我们对于谁会参与我们的研究有一个非常清晰的想法。
We were asking for people to come online and tell us about their experience, people who specifically voted for someone but told other people something else, that they voted for someone else or that they voted for no one or whatever it was. These were people who were not being forthright about their political support and keeping it secret. We just simply ask people, who are you keeping the secret from? Why and what are the effects? And these were secrets people were keeping
我们要求人们上线告诉我们他们的经历，特别是那些投给某人但告诉其他人是另一个人，或者投给无人或者诸如此类的人。这些人对他们的政治支持并不坦诚并将其保密。我们只是简单地问人们，你在对谁保密？为什么，以及有什么影响？这些是人们对他们的朋友、家人甚至配偶保密的秘密。
from their friends, family, and even their spouses. And we saw far more than we expected people who were saying that they were secretly supporting Trump. And when we asked people why, the number one reason expected people who were saying that they were secretly supporting Trump. And when we asked people why the number one reason was they were concerned for their reputation. They were concerned that people would think differently of them if they voiced publicly their support for Trump. And so it's interesting to think about what that means.
我们看到超出预期的人说他们秘密支持特朗普。当我们问人们原因时，头号原因超出预期的人说他们秘密支持特朗普。当我们问人们原因时，头号原因是因为他们担心自己的声誉。他们担心如果公开表达对特朗普的支持，人们会对他们有不同的看法。所以思考这意味着什么很有趣。
They weren't having conversations with others that maybe they should have had. And sort of the secondary reason people were keeping this a secret was not wanting to get in fights and not wanting to create arguments. And so if that was the reason why people felt they had to keep their secret. If it was just simply to avoid getting an arguments with the people around them, that didn't seem to be very harmful. And so this is this idea again coming that when you feel like it may not be easy, but you're doing it for the right thing. We see some less harm in secrecy, but when participants were especially concerned for their reputation,
他们没有与其他人进行他们也许应该进行的对话。人们保守秘密的次要原因是不想卷入争吵，不想引发争端。所以如果这就是人们觉得自己必须保守秘密的原因。如果仅仅是为了避免与周围的人发生争吵，那似乎并没有那么有害。所以这又是这个想法，当你觉得可能不容易，但你在做正确的事情时。我们在保守秘密中看到了较少的害处，但是当参与者特别担心他们的声誉时，
they found themselves having to think about the secret quite a bit, and the more they did so, the less authentic they felt with the people around them. less authentic they felt with the people around them. Examining the intention behind a secret can be a good way to understand what and whether it will cost you to keep it hidden. It's easy for example to shrug off a secret designed to avoid a political tiff with a coworker. Both you and your colleague now there are things you keep from each other to make work life go smoothly. But other secrets are not so easy to brush away.
他们发现自己不得不经常思考这个秘密，他们想得越多，他们就越觉得周围的人不够真实。他们越觉得周围的人不够真实。检查秘密背后的意图是了解保持秘密隐藏是否会让你付出代价的好方法。例如，很容易对付旨在避免与同事发生政治口角的秘密。你和你的同事都知道，有些事情你们互相隐瞒，以使工作生活顺利进行。但其他秘密没那么容易被刷掉。
That's because these secrets reveal what you think of others, what you think they think of you. They reveal your insecurities, your vulnerabilities. These secrets tend to produce one of the most damaging consequences to secret keeping. It's something that Michael calls mind wandering. Because a secret often feels something that's important to you or ongoing, because a secret often feels unresolved, because you haven't had the conversations you would normally have.
那是因为这些秘密揭示了你如何看待别人，你认为他们如何看待你。它们揭示了你的不安全感，你的脆弱性。这些秘密往往会产生保守秘密的最具破坏性的后果之一。这就是迈克尔所说的思想游离。因为秘密往往感觉像对你很重要或正在进行的事情，因为秘密往往感觉未解决，因为你没有进行你通常会进行的对话。
Our minds return to unresolved concerns and outstanding intentions and ongoing issues frequently because those are the things that require our attention. If something needs some kind of resolution or you need to work on something, whether you like or not, your mind is going gonna turn to it over and over. And people don't often put on their calendar, okay, from 10 a.m to 1030, I'm gonna think about my secret. People don't plan to think about their secret,
我们的思绪经常回到未解决的问题、突出的意图和正在进行的问题，因为那些是需要我们关注的事情。如果某事需要某种解决办法或者你需要处理某事，无论你喜欢与否，你的大脑都会一遍又一遍地转向它。人们通常不会在日历上安排，好的，从上午10点到10点半，我要思考我的秘密。人们并不打算去想他们的秘密，
but their secret comes to mind anyway. And so that's why we describe it as mind wandering. There's certain features about a secret that make it that your attention when you're not focused on a work task, when you're not focused on the thing in front of you, your mind can be drawn toward your secret. Things make you think of it, things make, remind you of it. And especially when it's something that you feel not good about or you feel alone with
但他们的秘密无论如何都会浮现在脑海中。所以这就是为什么我们将其描述为思想游离。秘密有某些特征，使你的注意力在你不专注于工作任务时，在你不专注于眼前的事情时，你的心思会被吸引到你的秘密上。事情让你想起它，事情让你、提醒你它。特别是当这是让你感觉不好或让你感到孤独或让你觉得虚假的事情。
or you feel inauthentic for. Once that secret comes to mind, it can be hard to put it down. And you talk at one point in your research studies about the difference between experiencing shame and experiencing guilt when it comes to secrets. I'm wondering if you can talk about that distinction, but also talk about it in the context of this mind-wondering idea,
一旦那个秘密浮现在脑海中，就很难把它放下来。你在研究中谈到过在面对秘密时经历羞耻感和经历内疚感之间的区别。我想知道你是否能谈谈这种区别，同时也在这种思想游离的想法背景下谈谈，
are secrets that are more tight to shame, more likely to cause our minds to return to them over and over again, or is guilt more likely to produce mind-wondering? Yeah, so psychologists make this very important distinction between these two words. And the idea is that when you feel guilty, you feel that something you've done is wrong. You've caused some harm. Your actions were wrong.
与羞耻感更紧密相连的秘密是否更有可能导致我们的思绪一遍又一遍地回到它们身上，还是内疚感更有可能产生思想游离？是的，心理学家对这两个词做出了非常重要的区分。这个想法是，当你感到内疚时，你觉得你所做的事情是错的。你造成了一些伤害。你的行动是错误的。
So when people feel guilty, they're more likely to feel remorse and be interested in making amends. But when you feel ashamed, you don't think about how your behavior was wrong. You think about how there's something wrong with you. When people feel ashamed, they feel like they're a bad person. And there's nothing they feel helpless and frozen. And there's nothing they can do about it. And so we find that when secrets make people feel ashamed,
所以当人们感到内疚时，他们更有可能感到懊悔并有兴趣做出弥补。但当你感到羞耻时，你不会认为你的行为是错误的。你认为你身上有什么不对劲。当人们感到羞耻时，他们觉得自己是个坏人。他们感到无助和僵化，对此无能为力。所以我们发现，当秘密让人感到羞耻时，
they're much more likely to have their mind turn over the secret over and over and the secret comes to mind much more frequently. So, when most of us think of secrets, I think the metaphor that I think jumps to mind is this metaphor of a shield. We have this vision of someone trying to pry the secret out of us and us trying to sort of hold the shield up to sort of defend ourselves or defend ourselves against someone breaking through our defenses. But I think the picture that you're painting here is almost a different kind of metaphor,
他们更有可能让自己的思绪一遍又一遍地翻转这个秘密，并且秘密浮现在脑海中的频率要高得多。所以，当大多数人想到秘密时，我想脑海中首先跳出的隐喻是盾牌的隐喻。我们有一种愿景，有人试图从我们这里套出秘密，而我们试图竖起盾牌来保护自己，或者保护自己免受某人突破我们的防线。但我认为你在这里描绘的画面几乎是另一种隐喻，
that it's really not the shield that really is motivating how we're thinking about secrets that are not minds. Yeah, you know, at the end of the day, people want to talk about these things. And secrecy is us stopping ourselves from doing so. And so you're right, it's not a shield. It's like a cork is the better metaphor perhaps.
真正激发我们思考秘密的不是盾牌，而是不是大脑。是的，你知道，归根结底，人们想谈论这些事情。而保守秘密就是我们阻止自己这样做。所以你是对的，这不是一个盾牌。也许塞子才是更好的隐喻。
We normally talk to other people to get their help and this is an instance where we're plugging that. We're not allowing that to happen and that has all these harmful consequences. When we come back, the effects of secrets on feelings of isolation and the paradoxical effect of being the owner of secrets in the workplace. You're listening to Hidden Brain and I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Michael Slepion studies the effects of keeping secrets and being the holder of secrets.
我们通常与其他人交谈以获得他们的帮助，而这是一个我们塞住它的例子。我们不允许这种情况发生，这带来了所有这些有害的后果。当我们回来时，秘密对孤立感的影响以及作为职场秘密拥有者的矛盾效应。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家迈克尔·斯莱皮安研究了保守秘密和作为秘密持有者的影响。
He finds that secrets can have pervasive effects in our lives. They make us feel less authentic, especially if our minds are constantly wandering back to the secret and wondering when we are going to reveal all. Michael, you started your exploration of secrets in part because you were interested in the metaphors people use when they talk about secrets, you know, they talk about the burden of a secret, for example. Talk to me about this idea that in some ways you started out looking at the role that metaphors might play and then you discovered something actually quite surprising when you conducted experiments into this. Yeah, so people have this curious way of talking about secrets.
他发现秘密会对我们的生活产生无处不在的影响。它们让我们感觉不那么真实，特别是如果我们的思绪不断游离回秘密，并想知道我们什么时候会把一切都抖出来。迈克尔，你开始探索秘密的部分原因是由于你对人们谈论秘密时使用的隐喻感兴趣，你知道，他们谈论秘密的负担，例如。跟我谈谈这个想法，即在某种程度上你开始研究隐喻可能扮演的角色，然后当你对此进行实验时，你发现了一些其实相当令人惊讶的事情。
People will say that they have a heavy secret or a secret, ways them down or they have to carry a secret around with them. People talk about a secret almost as if it's this physical way that they are weighed down by and have to carry with them. So our original studies were just interested in learning about that metaphor. Is that just something, is that just a figure of speech, or does that metaphor reflect actually how we think about secrets in a more deep way? In a series of studies, Michael asked people to think about secrets and then asked them
是的，人们有一种奇怪的谈论秘密的方式。人们会说他们有一个沉重的秘密，或者一个秘密压垮了他们，或者他们必须随身携带一个秘密。人们谈论秘密几乎就像它是一种物理方式，让他们感到沉重并不得不随身带着它。所以我们最初的研究只是对了解那个隐喻感兴趣。那只是一言语，还是那个隐喻确实反映了我们如何以更深刻的方式思考秘密？在一系列研究中，迈克尔让人们思考秘密，然后让他们
to judge the steepness of hills or other physical tasks. Volunteers judged hills as steeper and distances as further when they were burdened with a secret. It's as if the secret had spilled into the physical world and was weighing them down. You can see this in one scene in the TV show The Office. The character Kevin successfully manages to hold on to the secret that one of his colleagues is having an affair with another colleague's spouse. I knew it the whole time. I kept the secret, I kept the secret so good, you didn't freaking know, but I knew.
判断山坡的陡峭程度或其他体力任务。当背负着秘密时，志愿者们认为山更陡峭，距离更遥远。就好像秘密已经溢出到物理世界中并让他们感到沉重。你可以在电视剧《办公室》的一个场景中看到这一点。角色凯文成功地保守了一个秘密，即他的一个同事与另一个同事的配偶有染。我一直都知道。我保守了这个秘密，我把秘密保守得很好，你他妈的不知道，但我知道。
He knew. Yes. We did it. You did it, Kevin. Yes. Oh, I did it. What's striking to me, Michael, is the relief that we hear in Kevin's voice when he no longer has to hold on to the secret. That's big exactly to what you're just talking about. Yeah. Yeah, it feels good to get it off our chest, but just getting it off your chest isn't enough.
他知道了。是的。我们做到了。你做到了，凯文。是的。哦，我做到了。迈克尔，让我震惊的是，我们在凯文的声音中听到的解脱，当他不再需要保守秘密时。这完全符合你刚才所说的。是的。是的，卸下心头大石的感觉很好，但仅仅卸下心头大石是不够的。
It's having a conversation about that secret, which is actually when you get the help that you need. And so for example, we're revealing a secret anonymously online. That does feel really good to sort of anonymously just put your secret out in the world, but it's not as good as talking to another person about it. not only just put your secret out in the world, but it's not as good as talking to another person about it. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in said secret telephone, get something off your chest, and if you picked up the receiver, you could listen to secrets people had previously shared with the phone and you could leave your own. I gave up my keto diet because of waffles.
是关于这个秘密展开对话，而这其实正是你获得所需帮助的时候。因此，举个例子，我们在网上匿名吐露一个秘密。匿名把你的秘密公之于众，这种感觉确实相当不错，但它不如跟另一个人谈论这个秘密好。不仅是把秘密公之于众，而且它不如跟另一个人谈论这个秘密好。说出那个秘密电话，卸下心头大石，如果你拿起听筒，就能听到别人以前在这个电话里分享过的秘密，你也可以留下自己的秘密。我因为华夫饼而放弃了生酮饮食。
Dating is exhausting and I'm afraid I'm going to die alone. I like to eat egg salad on the toilet. Where do I, where do I hang up? So the speaks to what you just said a second ago. So in some ways this was a, this was a way to, for people to get the secrets off their chest, but not necessarily to have a conversation with someone about it. Yeah, and you know, if you're starting point is you haven't told a single soul and you think you'll never will, getting it off your chest is a really great starting point because you realize this is something I can say out loud.
约会太累了，我怕我会孤独终老。我喜欢在马桶上吃鸡蛋沙拉。我该在哪里，该在哪里挂断电话？所以这印证了你刚才说的话。所以在某种程度上，这是一个让人们一吐为快的方式，但不一定是与某人就此展开对话。是的，你知道，如果你 的起点是“你没有告诉过任何人，而且你认为自己永远不会说”，那么一吐为快真的是一个非常好的起点，因为你会意识到这是一件我可以大声说出来的事情。
Maybe this is something I can move forward on. Maybe this is not so bad. Maybe it's not as bad as I think, but you're more likely to arrive at those helpful conclusions if you're on conversation with another person. So it's a great place to get started and hopefully it motivated people to think,
也许这是一件我可以继续向前推进的事情。也许这并没有那么糟糕。也许它没有我想象的那么糟，但如果你与另一个人对话，你更有可能得出这些有益的结论。所以这是一个很好的开始，希望它能激励人们去思考：
oh, actually I can talk about this with someone to you next time. I'm wondering if part of the reason we hesitate to share secrets is that we imagine people will relate to us as if they were strangers, but the act of sharing secrets with someone communicates to them, look, I trust you, I trust that I'm sharing something that makes me vulnerable with you, and that act of trust in some ways transforms this person from being a stranger to someone that we trust.
哦，实际上下次我可以和别人谈谈这个。我想我们犹豫要不要分享秘密的部分原因，是我们想象别人会把我们当作陌生人来对待，但与某人分享秘密的行为向他们传达了：看，我信任你，我相信我向你分享了一些让我感到脆弱的事情，而这种信任的行为在某种程度上把这个人从陌生人变成了我们信任的人。
And is it possible that in some ways, we underestimate the power that sharing our secrets has on other people, on the effects that it will have on them in terms of their ability to respond well to us? Absolutely, I think people totally underestimate that. Some people are aware of it, but I think some people miss out on this way to use our sensitive personal information that, you know, when we're feeling comfortable with someone, even if we only just met them, revealing something sensitive as a surefire way to sort of jumpstart that
而且有没有可能在某种程度上，我们低估了分享秘密对其他人的力量，低估了它在他们对我们做出良好反应的能力方面产生的影响？绝对的，我认为人们完全低估了这一点。有些人意识到了这一点，但我认为有些人错失了利用我们的敏感个人信息的方法，你知道的，当我们对某人感到舒适时，即使我们才刚认识他们，透露一些敏感的事情也是一种万无一失的方法，可以以此来启动这段
relationship or deepen that relationship in its way to sort of form these social connections and deepen them. I'm wondering if you can talk about the effects of secrets in the workplace. Many people at companies have to hold secrets and this is especially true for executives or managers. What effects does this have on them? So, this is an interesting situation because now it's not necessarily your choice to have kept the secret. This might be something enforced from up above.
关系，或者深化这段关系，以此来建立这些社会联系并加深它们。我想知道你是否能谈谈秘密对工作场所的影响。许多公司的员工必须保守秘密，对于高管或经理来说尤其如此。这会对他们产生什么影响？所以，这是一个有趣的情况，因为现在保守秘密不一定是你的选择。这可能是上面强制执行的。
And so we find that in some ways, a secret that you have to keep on behalf of your workplace looks a lot like a personal secret in some ways, but there's some important differences to you. So the similarity is it can be isolating. If there's something really significant going on in your work life that you're not allowed to tell your spouse about, that you're not even allowed
因此我们发现，在某种程度上，你必须代表工作场所保守的秘密，在某些方面看起来很像个人秘密，但它们有一些重要的不同之处。相似之处在于它可能会带来孤立感。如果你的工作生活中发生了非常重要的事情，而你被禁止告诉你的配偶，甚至被禁止
to tell other co-workers about, that's just a frustrating experience of being isolated with that information. And it's not easy just because, you know, normally being able to talk about work, that's one of the major conversation topics with other people and not being able to have that conversation that is frustrating and isolating.
告诉其他同事，那带着这些信息被孤立起来就会是一段令人沮丧的经历。而且这并不容易，因为你知道，通常能够谈论工作是与他人交流的主要话题之一，而无法进行那样的对话会令人沮丧且感到孤立。
But there is a silver lining. If your boss is giving you something very high-level information to keep secret, you recognize that you're being trusted with really sensitive information. And the personal domain that Foster is feeling some intimacy in the workplace domain, that Foster is feeling of status. I'm wondering if you have any thoughts about the effects the COVID pandemic may have had on the way we think and keep secrets. Certainly, at a minimum, people who are working from home no longer have sort of the distance
但也有好的一面。如果你的老板给你非常高层的信息让你保密，你会意识到你被信任以极其敏感的信息。而在个人领域，这会培养出工作场所领域中的一种亲密感，从而培养出一种地位感。我想知道你对新冠大流行可能对我们思考和保守秘密的方式产生的影响有什么看法。当然，至少，居家办公的人们不再拥有那种与他们的伴侣和家庭生活的距离
from their partners and home life that they might have once had when they were working in a workplace. Do you feel like COVID has meant that there are actually fewer secrets within families because people are seeing more of their partners, more of the time? You know, maybe it's so hard to know how this might have an effect. You know, the way I've thought about it
而这种距离是他们过去在工作场所上班时可能曾拥有的。你觉得新冠疫情意味着家庭内部的秘密实际上变少了吗，因为人们有更多时间见到更多的伴侣？你知道，也许很难知道这会产生什么影响。你知道，我一直在思考的方式是
is at the very least, it's reduced the number of in-person interactions we have. And I think when people think about the difficulties of concealment, they're kind of thinking about live interactions, not conversations on Zoom. Conversations on Zoom are more often down to business, and there's not like, chitchat, like, how was your summer? You know, we kind of get down to business a little sooner.
至少，它减少了我们的面对面互动次数。我认为当人们想到隐瞒的困难时，他们想的是现场互动，而不是Zoom上的对话。Zoom上的对话往往开门见山直奔主题，没有诸如“你夏天过得怎么样？”之类的闲聊。你知道，我们更早地切入正题。
So I think in some ways, it might be easier to keep secrets from the people now you're no longer seeing in person. Now could spending more time with your partner and make secrecy harder, or data doesn't exactly suggest that, whether you spend a lot of time or not much time, that doesn't seem to be what matters so much.
所以我认为在某种程度上，向那些你不再亲自见面的人保守秘密可能会更容易。现在，花更多的时间和伴侣在一起会使保守秘密变得更难吗，还是数据并没有确切表明这一点？不管你花很多时间还是很少时间，这似乎都不是最关键的。
It's again, whether you feel alone with a secret or ashamed to have it or inauthentic to have it. Now maybe when you're around your partner more, maybe you're reminded of your secret more. And in that case, it might get harder. Before the pandemic, when Michael was still interacting with people face to face, he had a secret of his own that weighed on him for years.
关键仍然在于，你是否觉得守着一个秘密很孤单，或者为此感到羞耻，或者觉得这样做很不真实。现在，也许当你和伴侣在一起更多时，你可能更多地想起了你的秘密。在这种情况下，事情可能会变得更难。在大流行之前，当迈克尔还在与人们面对面互动时，他有一个保守了多年的秘密，这个秘密压得他喘不过气来。
It all started while he was talking with his colleagues at Columbia about an upcoming summer break. So in this instance I was uh yep telling people I'm going to be away for a week I'm going to be um unplugged and spending time with my friends in California. And were you in fact going to California? Yes, but it was just a pit stop to continue on somewhere else. Michael, in fact, was heading to Burning Mountain, an annual gathering in the Nevada Desert. I think when people hear that term, they sort of imagine like a bunch of naked people out in the desert doing drugs
这一切都始于他在哥伦比亚大学与同事谈论即将到来的暑假时。所以在这个例子中，我呃，是的，告诉大家我要离开一周，我要去呃，断网，和我在加利福尼亚的朋友们一起度过时光。你当时真的要去加利福尼亚吗？是的，但这只是去别处的中转站。事实上，迈克尔正前往内华达州沙漠中的“火人节”（Burning Mountain/Burning Man）。我想当人们听到这个词时，他们会想象就像一群赤身裸体的在沙漠里吸毒的人
and who knows what else, which is heartily happening for sure, people tug each other even if they're strangers and there's just a lot of sort of social connection and emphasis on creativity and sort of self-expression and freedom of expression and inclusivity. But there's a lot of other things as well. It's, festival's not quite the right word, but it's like an arts festival and sort of a massive social gathering. It's creating an entire city from scratch that wasn't there before and a totally functional city for a week and more.
谁知道还有什么，这种事当然也确实存在，人们甚至与陌生人拥抱，这里有大量的社会联系，强调创造力、自我表达、言语自由和包容性。但还有很多其他的事情。这是一个，“节日”这个词不太准确，但它就像一个艺术节和一个大型的社交聚会。它从无到有创造了一座完整的城市，一座在一周或更长时间内完全运转的城市，而这座城市之前并不存在。
And then taking it entirely away, leaving, you know, not a trace behind. And that's what I was keeping secret from my colleagues that I was participating in that. And it's striking because all the things that you just said, are things that I think you would be perfectly happy saying that you subscribe to, that you're all for social connection and inclusivity and all of those things. What, why did you feel like you could not tell your colleagues
然后又把它完全拆除，不留下（你知道的）一丝痕迹。这就是我对同事保密的秘密——我参与了其中。这很引人注目，因为你刚刚所说的一切，都是我认为你会非常乐意宣称你赞同的事情，即你完全支持社会联系、包容性以及所有这些事情。你为什么会觉得你不能告诉你的同事
where you were going? The idea of discussing this at work, it just felt like I couldn't. It was somehow not appropriate or not professional. And I'm imagining this scenario when they were like, oh, were you naked? Did you do drugs? What did you do there? And just feeling like, I can't talk about this with you. Michael wasn't just uncomfortable that a colleague might imagine him in a not suitable for work situation.
你要去哪里？在工作中讨论这个想法，让我觉得我做不到。这在某种程度上是不恰当的或不专业的。我能想象到这种场景，当他们问：哦，你们是光着身子吗？你们吸毒了吗？你们在那里做了什么？然后就会觉得，我没法和你们谈论这个。迈克尔不仅是不安于同事可能会想象他身处不适合工作的情境中，
He worried about the cascading effect of the secret getting out. So like, can imagine I tell one colleague, it's like, okay, now what happens to that information? Did, you know, does that spread to the next colleague and I might no longer control over it? I think that's sort of the concern. So when you came back and had these conversations
他还担心秘密泄露带来的连锁反应。就像你可以想象我告诉一个同事，心想：好吧，那信息接下来会怎么样？你知道，这会传播给下一个同事吗，我是不是可能无法再控制它了？我认为这差不多就是顾虑所在。所以当你回来，在那个夏天结束时与这些人交谈时，
with people at the end of that summer, what did you tell people when they said, how was your unplugged vacation in California? What did you say? It's so funny because I felt so uncomfortable answering it because I'm like dancing around this thing and saying like, oh, it was great. Or like, it's great to be back, which actually is not what it definitely feels like at all,
当他们问“你在加利福尼亚的断网假期过得怎么样？”你对他们说了什么？太搞笑了，因为我回答时感到非常不自在，因为我在这个事情周围兜圈子，说：哦，太棒了。或者像，很高兴回来，这实际上根本不是我当时真正感受到的，
but it's just, it feels weird to like try to answer her question and just to step over this huge secret in the process. Yeah. Did you have the same feeling that Lauren did that after some time, the secret felt like it was growing that it had taken on a life of its own? Well, there's a point at which you're like stepping over the secret, dancing around information with different people. And maybe I think I did tell one person, but I was like, oh no, like that person will
但这只是，试图回答她的问题并在过程中跨过这个巨大的秘密，感觉很怪异。是的。你是否有和劳伦一样的情绪，觉得过了一段时间后，这个秘密感觉越来越大，仿佛有了它自己的生命？嗯，有那么一个时刻，你会觉得自己在跨过这个秘密，与不同的人在信息周围兜圈子。也许我想我确实告诉过一个人，但我当时想：哦不，就像这个人会
they know not to talk to this person. And it does sort of grow in your mind. And it's like, well, what do you do? What's a striking, of course, is that you will be having exactly like your research subjects in your experiments, whose minds kept wandering back to the thing they were trying to keep secret. Yeah, that's entirely right. I'm trying not to lie in answering people's questions.
他们知道不要跟这个人谈论。这确实会在你脑海中膨胀。然后就会想，嗯，你该怎么办？当然，引人注目的是，你将变得和你的实验研究对象完全一样，他们的思绪不断飘回他们试图保密的那个事情上。是的，完全正确。我在回答别人的问题时尽量不撒谎。
And so the only way to do that without just saying something that's flat out untrue is to give really short responses to questions. And that is definitely a form of social distancing. And that itself might sort of prompt people to say, okay, Michael really doesn't want to talk about what happened on a summer vacation. Or maybe even Michael doesn't want to be friends with me because he's giving me monosyllabic answers
因此，在不直言不讳地撒谎的情况下做到这一点的唯一方法，就是对问题给出非常简短的回答。这绝对是一种社交疏离的形式。而这本身可能会促使人们说：好吧，迈克尔真的不想谈论他在暑假发生了什么。或者甚至迈克尔不想和我做朋友，因为他对我在暑假做了什么的问题给出了
to my questions about what he did on a summer vacation. Yeah, I think definitely I felt myself not connecting during the very moment of which I could have. But Michael did end up sharing his secret. Sort of. After their third summer at Burning Man, his wife asked him if it was okay for her to post a picture of the event on Facebook, a picture that Michael was in. And he said, sure. And that was sort of a first step in making it not entirely secret. But of course, as is our world today, of course,
单音节的回答。是的，我确实觉得自己在可以建立联系的关键时刻没有去连接。但迈克尔最终还是分享了他的秘密。某种程度上是这样的。在他们参加火人节的第三个夏天之后，他的妻子问他是否可以把一张活动的相片发到脸书（Facebook）上，那张照片里有迈克尔。他说，可以。这可以说是迈克尔迈出的第一步，让这个秘密不再完全是秘密。但当然，正如我们当今的世界一样，当然，
I'm like Facebook friends with colleagues. And so by letting it sort of sit there, I was opening up the possibility that this is not going to be secret any longer. Although this was a secluded way of revealing the secret, it didn't take long for his colleagues to pick up on it. When school was back in session, all of Michael's colleagues gathered for a beginning of the year seminar. Everyone attends, and so it was this full-packed stadium seating lecture hall. And you know, people are just chatting, you know, talking about their summer break. And I hear someone behind me say, oh, hey, how is Burning Man?
我和同事们是脸书好友。因此，通过让它那样静静地呆在那里，我是在敞开这种可能性：这个秘密将不再是秘密。尽管这是一种隐蔽的泄露秘密的方式，但他的同事们并没有花多久就发现了。当学校重新开学时，迈克尔的所有同事都聚集在一起参加年头研讨会。每个人都出席了，所以这是一个座无虚席的阶梯教室。你知道，大家都在闲聊，谈论他们的暑假。然后我听到身后有人说：哦，嘿，火人节怎么样？
And I had to take a moment. I was like, wait, no, this is not how I intended for this to go for this just to be spoken out loud inside of a lecture hall. And what did you say in that moment, besides feeling like you wanted to vanish into a small hole, what did you say? I think I just was like, good. It was, it was certainly not something I wanted to talk about at length at that moment. That person later immediately understood that and said, hey, sorry, I didn't mean to like out you if that's what I did. And at that moment, I started realizing, you know, maybe life would be easier for this
我不得不停顿了一下。我想：等等，不，这不是我想要的节奏，不希望这件事就在一个阶梯教室里被大声说出来。在那一刻你说了什么，除了感觉自己想钻进一个小洞里之外，你说了什么？我想我只是说：很好。这绝对不是我当时想长篇大论的事情。那个人后来立刻明白了，说：嘿，对不起，我不是故意要曝光你的，如果我真的这么做了的话。就在那一刻，我开始意识到，你知道，也许对这件事来说生活会更轻松
to not be a secret. I thought it was the other way around. I thought life would be easier to this to not be a secret. I thought it was the other way around. I thought life would be easier to just hold it back from people at work. But then I'm sort of, you know, doing these awkward dances around information and giving short answers to questions. And maybe that's not better. So how did you change your behavior after that, Michael? What did you do?
不要把它当成秘密。我以为事实恰好相反。我以为对工作中的人们隐瞒这个秘密会让生活更轻松。但后来我有点像，你知道的，在信息周围做着这些尴尬的盘旋，对问题给出简短的回答。也许那样并没有更好。迈克尔，在那之后你是如何改变你的行为的？你做了什么？
So I think this conversation we're having is certainly the biggest step in that direction. I still don't go around walking up to my senior colleagues, the folks who were deciding my tenure case saying, hey, this thing I just came back from, but I do probably talk about it more freely with my junior colleagues now. I'm wondering, did anyone have the reaction that you either implicitly or explicitly fear? Did anyone think less of you, Michael, as a result of their learning that you went to Burning Man? I see the nature of regression. I think you're right that the answer is, no, I think people were like, that's cool.
所以我想我们现在进行的这场对话无疑是朝着那个方向迈出的最大一步。我仍然不会到处走到我资深的同事、那些决定我终身教授职位的人面前说：嘿，这是我刚从那个地方回来，但我现在可能会更自由地和年轻同事谈论它。我在想，有没有人做出你隐性或显性恐惧的反应？迈克尔，有没有人因为得知你去过火人节而对你看低？我看到了回归的本质。我想你是对的，答案是：没有，我觉得人们的反应是：太酷了。
It wasn't this terrible thing that I imagined. And I'm wondering what that reveals, because I think in one level it might reveal, of course, that your fears were out of whack with reality, which is, of course, a useful insight for us to have. But I'm also wondering if it reveals something else, which is that when we think about our secrets, we are often consumed and obsessed with our own lives and our lives loom large in our own imaginations, because they're, of course, our lives. And we imagine mistakenly that other people are just as interested in our lives
它并不是我想象中那种可怕的事情。我想知道这揭示了什么，因为我认为在某种程度上，它可能揭示出，你的恐惧与现实脱节了，这当然对我们来说是一个有用的洞察。但我也在想，它是否揭示了其他东西——也就是说，当我们思考自己的秘密时，我们往往被自己的生活所吞噬和痴迷，我们的生活在自己的想象中占据了很大比重，因为它们当然就是我们的生活。我们错误地想象别人对我们的生活也同样感兴趣，
as we are in what happens to us, and much at the time they're not. That's perfectly correct. You know, this is the problem with having a secret that you're not talking about with other people. Of course, you're going to imagine the worst-case scenario. What's to stop you once you start talking about it from people, you realize how far away that worst case scenario is. You know, when we started this episode, we talked about Lauren and we talked about her experience and her growing concern that now the secret
就像我们对自己身上发生的事情一样，而很多时候他们并不是这样。完全正确。你知道，这就是带着一个你没有与其他人谈论的秘密所带来的问题。当然，你会想象最坏的情况。一旦你开始和别人谈论它，你就会发现最坏的情况离现实有多远，从而打破这种想象。你知道，当我们开始这一集节目时，我们谈到了劳伦以及她的经历，她越来越担心，现在这个她对朋友和同事隐瞒的秘密，
that she was keeping from her friends and co-worker was actually not her biggest concern anymore. Her biggest concern was they would find out that she had kept a secret from them. A secret that in their minds was actually quite trivial. They wouldn't think less of her because of the secret. They would think less of her because she had kept a secret from them. Yeah, I definitely understand that experience. And there's so many things that just happen
其实已经不再是她最大的担忧了。她最大担忧的是他们会发现她对他们隐瞒了一个秘密。一个在他们看来其实相当琐碎的秘密。他们不会因为这个秘密而看低她。他们会因为她对他们隐瞒了秘密而看低她。是的，我绝对理解那种经历。当你保守秘密时，
when you keep a secret. You know, not only now, or you're trying to figure out how to handle this information, how do you handle the fact that you've been keeping a secret for so long, if you're eventually going to talk about it with someone, it's a tough one. [♪ Music playing, piano and piano music playing, this was the uncomfortable position that Lauren was in when I first interviewed her many months ago.
会发生如此多的事情。你知道，不仅现在，你还在想方设法如何处理这些信息，如果你最终要和某人谈论它，你要如何应对这样一个事实：你保守这个秘密已经这么久了，这是一个艰难的抉择。[♪ 音乐播放，钢琴曲播放，这就是劳伦在许多个月前我第一次采访她时所处的尴尬境地。
She had responded to a request we made, asking listeners to share their secrets. But when I caught up with her recently, she told me she had become much more open about sharing her secret. She's found that talking plainly has not only made her life less complicated, it's made her feel better. It's like she doesn't have a load on her shoulders anymore. We had the very same thing from many people who shared their secrets with us. Thank you so much for taking the time to listen.
她回应了我们的一个请求，要求听众分享他们的秘密。但当我最近联系她时，她告诉我，她在分享秘密方面已经变得开放多了。她发现坦诚地交谈不仅让她的生活不那么复杂，还让她感觉更好了。就好像她的肩膀上不再背负重担一样。我们在许多与我们分享秘密的人身上都听到了同样的反馈。非常感谢您抽出时间收听。
It felt like a weight left it off my shoulders. I'm hopeful, you know? I can talk about the secret now, because I realize now it's just the truth. I think at the end of the day, people just don't wanna be alone. They wanna be alone with something. Don't wanna be alone with this set of thoughts
感觉卸下了肩上的重担。你知道，我充满希望。我现在可以谈论这个秘密了，因为我现在意识到这只是真相。我认为归根结底，人们只是不想孤单。他们不想独自面对某些事情。不想独自面对这组想法
because it's hard to say, okay, I'm alone with this thing and I'm not gonna talk about it with other people. I think why it feels good. I think it's not just that someone has heard it, but you're no longer alone with it. When he isn't at Burning Man, Michael Slepian is a psychologist at Columbia University. Michael, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me.
因为很难说，好吧，我独自面对这件事，我不会和其他人谈论它。我想为什么这感觉很好。我想不仅是有人听到了，而是你不再孤单了。当不在火人节时，迈克尔·斯莱皮安（Michael Slepian）是哥伦比亚大学的心理学家。迈克尔，非常感谢你今天做客“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）。谢谢邀请我。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our Ronson Heroes today are Ben and John Adair. Ben runs the LA-based podcast production company Western Sound. At the start of the pandemic, he and his team needed a solution for how to record guests while everyone was staying at home.
“隐藏的大脑”由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。Midrall Media 是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、奥秋·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）和安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。我们今天的“朗森英雄”（Ronson Heroes）是本（Ben）和约翰·阿代尔（John Adair）。本经营着一家总部位于洛杉矶的播客制作公司 Western Sound。大流行刚开始时，他和他的团队需要一个解决方案，以便在每个人都居家隔离时录制嘉宾。
So Ben and his twin brother, John, created that solution, an app called Toxinc. We've been using Toxinc to record our interview since the fall, and it's made independent production so much easier. Thank you, Ben and John, for seeing a problem and developing a solution that can benefit so many of us in the podcasting community. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因此，本和他的双胞胎兄弟约翰创造了那个解决方案，一款名为 Toxinc 的应用程序。从秋季开始，我们一直使用 Toxinc 来录制我们的采访，这让独立制作变得容易得多。谢谢本和约翰，感谢你们发现问题并开发出能够造福播客社区中我们许多人的解决方案。想了解更多“隐藏的大脑”的内容，您可以在脸书（Facebook）和推特（Twitter）上关注我们。如果您喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。下周见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。